look at this guy
do you feel old yet because i sure do
that was me the last time amd had a
truly competitive top tier radeon
graphics card that was over seven years
ago
and this is me the last time amd sat on
top as the single gpu king with the
radeon hd 7970 and that is why the
excitement around the rx 6800 series is
so high
and why it would be so devastating if
amd let us all down again
thankfully spoiler alert
they didn't
watch on
and watch what apps are stealing your
bandwidth using our sponsor glasswire
it's an easy way to diagnose and fix
issues like poor video quality in online
meetings get 25 off today using offer
code linus at the link down below
during episode two of amd's where gaming
begins event amd introduced us to their
three new big navi gpus the rx 6800 rx
6800 xt and rx 6900 xt nice all of which
feature ray accelerators in each compute
unit for ray tracing support as well as
16 gigabytes of gddr6 memory and a new
infinity cache that promises to
significantly improve memory performance
without the additional cost associated
with gddr6x
not only that but amd also announced a
technology that they're calling smart
access memory which lets compatible cpus
access the gpu's entire memory space at
once rather than in small 256 megabyte
chunks as before offering a significant
performance boost
it's because of that last feature that
we're using a top-end ryzen 5000 series
cpu for our testing which along with
offering leading gaming performance is
the only cpu platform that currently
supports this feature
before you get too concerned about being
left out though both amd and nvidia have
told us that it's pretty much a fancy
marketing name for resizable bar support
which is something that microsoft is
pushing for and that nvidia claims will
be supported on their gpus soon i'd also
be surprised if we don't see intel ad
platform support in the future but the
future's the future let's see how things
look today shadow of the tomb raider was
one of the first titles to support ray
tracing and with it disabled nvidia
stands no chance against amd
unless we enabled dlss and that's a big
deal but there is an asterisk here when
we turn on ray tracing radeon
performance suffers tremendously with
the 6800 xt sitting 13 frames per second
below the rtx 3080.
we wanted to test the same thing in
wolfenstein youngblood but unfortunately
that game hasn't been updated yet with
vulcan ray tracing support for amd so
we'll have to settle for a traditional
rendering where the 6800 xt is once
again trailing the rtx 3080 with another
asterisk
with smart access memory enabled amd
retakes the lead in this traditional
rendering scenario with a single digit
but measurable performance improvement
more good news follows with microsoft
flight simulator where amd managed the
same or better performance than nvidia
across the board although here we see a
scenario where smart access memory has
no tangible benefit so your mileage
quite literally can vary game to game
cs go gives us one scenario where nvidia
pulls ahead in traditional rasterized
rendering but look at the difference in
minimum frame rates
smart access memory makes a huge
difference for amd here and arguably
that's even more important for esports
titles like this than the average frame
rate would be
finally there's minecraft rtx and it's
well it's a mess on amd
even without dlss the 6800 xt only gets
half the average fps compared to the rtx
3080 and even the rtx 3070 is 50 faster
than the 6800 this really highlights the
weakness of amd's first generation ray
accelerators compared to nvidia's more
mature second gen rt cores
a note on dlss before we continue
dlss is a contentious thing because it's
an upscaler the scene is rendered at a
lower resolution and then intelligently
scaled up using nvidia's tensor course
some would call measuring performance
with dlss cheating but whether it's
cheating or whether it's not it looks
pretty darn good and it's something real
gamers are using that amd doesn't yet
have an answer for
if fidelityfx super resolution which is
their analogous feature were ready in
time for launch then we might have had
playable frame rates in minecraft with
ray tracing enabled but instead we'll
need to wait for the rx 6900 xt get
subscribed by the way so you don't miss
our coverage of that card when it
launches in december now productivity
used to be an area that radeon excelled
but it seems that amd had to make some
sacrifices to catch up in gaming
in opencl versus cuda radeon outperforms
g-force in longer renders while the
opposite is true for shorter renders
like bmw
radeon doesn't currently support
ray-accelerated rendering which puts
nvidia light years ahead with their
optics renderer and it's worth noting
that while there is a plug-in for radeon
prorender that is accelerated the output
is rough and looks nothing like what it
should
similarly we couldn't even run luxmark
or rather we could but the end result
was so mangled that it wasn't even
recognizable let alone usable
this led to a problem for us in terms of
productivity testing because most
productivity software that takes
advantage of the gpu is optimized for
cuda and opencl implementations are
getting old enough now that they're
beginning to break
we did find a renderer that supports
both opencl and cuda indigo but
nvidia had the lead in it anyway
spec view perf gave us some blow trading
though with 3ds max performing better on
radeons while katia and creo were much
better on geforce and the memory
intensive energy medical and siemens nx
workloads heavily favored radeon thanks
to the infinity cache
mayan solidworks on the other hand once
again fell to nvidia's faster compute
engine
as amd predicted when we asked about its
impact on productivity smart access
memory made no difference here just like
our new keyboard shirts won't make you a
better typist they just make you look
cooler lttestore.com
it looks like amd's expanded vapor
chamber cooler design though is roughly
comparable to nvidia's with both the rx
6800 gpus closely matching their team
green counterparts with the curious
exception of the tail end of the test
where specvuperf's medical and siemens
nx benchmarks happen to fall as you
might recall that's one of the areas
where amd absolutely spanked nvidia
as far as clock stability goes it looks
like amd is slightly less consistently
running at maximum boost clock but it's
pretty similar across the board
you might expect that with clocks going
as low as they do at idle power
consumption would be lower than nvidia's
when you're not doing anything
unfortunately that's not so
still power consumption on the whole
appears lower with some exceptions so
you can again see that dip for nvidia
here suggesting a bottleneck with
medical and siemens nx that amd isn't
experiencing you can't see it on this
graph unfortunately but we recorded a
spike as high as 270 watts for the rx
6800 and an eye watering 411 watts for
the 6800 xt
thankfully that's not all the time so
it's not really a problem in practice
that is as long as you've got a quality
power supply that won't trip its over
current protection under a momentary
spike like that
the main trouble with the rx 6800 series
aside from the last gen ray tracing
performance which is becoming more
important day by day
is its lack of truly useful features in
comparison to nvidia
not only do they not yet have a dlss
equivalent that's ready to help out
their weaker ray accelerators they're
not even apologetic about it here's what
they told us when we asked about the ray
tracing performance and why they weren't
comparing with nvidia even for press
briefings super resolution techniques
like dlss do not produce the same visual
quality as native rendering especially
with motion
i mean
yeah that's true but it's gotten pretty
good and that fact alone doesn't change
that nvidia has it and amd doesn't and
that was literally the difference
between playable ray tracing and sub 60
frame rates in our testing also amd if
you really thought it was that garbage
why are you working on an analogous
feature
like we weren't expecting amd to blow us
away with their first gen ray tracing
support it's just that this fox and the
grapes response is a little bit tone
deaf
of course amd has a point not everyone
cares about upscaling or ray tracing but
then amd's hardware video encoder is
still frankly rubbish with what looks
like significant chroma subsampling and
macroblock artifacts compared to nvidia
at the same resolution in bitrate and
x264
it's basically unwatchable and on the
subject of media nvidia is also rolling
features like rtx voice background noise
cancellation ai camera background
removal and more that are accelerated by
their tensor cores
amd currently has no equivalent machine
learning hardware in the radeon 6000
series this puts streamers and content
creators and frankly even work from home
professionals who like to game in their
off hours at a disadvantage with radeon
compared to if they had bought geforce
instead
speaking personally those features
really are enough to compel me to go
geforce even if i didn't give two hoots
about ray tracing amd is trying to make
up for this somewhat though by focusing
more on game enhancements via variable
rate shading mesh shading and fidelity
effects
but these are up to the developer to
include you can't just turn on the
ambient occlusion feature on any game
that you want
this combined with enhanced media
decoding support and support for full
fat hdmi 2.1 with freesync
well they merely bring amd up to date
rather than allowing them to leap over
nvidia who already has mesh shading
variable rate shading ambient occlusion
sharpening on top of all the other
things that amd's missing out on here
so
i'm not disappointed by the rx 6800
series amd delivered on everything they
promised in their keynote but if you
were hoping that there was going to be
some extra dazzle you know one more
thing
then you might feel a bit let down
what you see is what you get and at
these prices
they're just a little tough to recommend
the rx 6800 xt is just fifty dollars
less than the rtx 3080 and gets you
roughly similar performance in
traditional gaming with a big l in
almost every other area the rx 6800 well
honestly it's even tougher at 80 dollars
more than the competing rtx 3070 well it
competes well until you turn on ray
tracing
or start streaming
but it's also only 70 dollars more for
the significantly faster xt model which
doesn't seem like a lot more by the time
you're already spending 600 on a
freaking graphics card
so maybe the 6800 exists mostly as like
a kicker sku and we'll see some crazy
promotions on it or something
all in all a plus for effort but anyone
who wanted to see nvidia get absolutely
embarrassed this generation is just
gonna have to wait for amd's next crack
at top tier gaming performance
though amd's probably still gonna move a
lot of these given that you can't
actually buy an rtx card at the moment
now that i think about it
just like i always think about our
segways get the best prices and best
selection on pc hardware and technology
at any of microcenter's 25 locations
across the united states micro centers
got new prices on the 9th generation 8
core cpus from intel with the 9700k at
just 199 and 9900k at 299 and you can
save an additional 20 bucks when you
bundle with a compatible eligible
motherboard and you can follow the link
in the description for a free 32gb flash
drive and 32gb microsd card valid in
store only no purchase necessary really
no purchase necessary how the hell does
that work well thanks for watching guys
go check out our coverage of amd's where
gaming begins to get a little more
background on today's launch we decided
to focus this video more on just like
the performance and feature analysis let
us know if you like that approach